people are at the heart of the EU Africa
partnership so policy strategies must
deliver benefits to citizens in terms of
jobs education health and women's rights
but the generational challenges are
different Africa has the world's
youngest population and it's set to
double in less than 40 years in contrast
the number of EU retirees could almost
double over the same period Africans
require training to find jobs young
people and women are particularly
seeking opportunities in the formal
workplace and to develop their own
industry investments key to unlocking
Africa's entrepreneurial spirit the
energy of young and dynamic communities
with benefits that could flow back into
Europe but poverty and climate change
are a growing challenge the Africa EU
vision is to build a common agenda on
policies to address global warming and
land degradation Africa faces extreme
weather with food security and water
supply issues and these are a major
concern to both continents the time when
you expect raise it is drought when you
expect the dry season there is rain in
these days the droughts have become too
frequent they become much longer and
much more intense in its effects
education is another field with the EU
in Africa a working hand in hand
encouraging policy dialogue between
governments regions and development
agencies to share lessons learned in the
health sector Africa's made great
strides in combating aids tuberculosis
and malaria while Europe's providing
better medicines and vaccines to reduce
child mortality and of course people
means movement migration and mobility
the Africa EU relationship aims to ease
travel to create more and better jobs
but also to channel legal migration and
refugee flows while finding solutions
for irregular migration
you